المنافسه الجمهوريه الوحيده التي بقيت في
السباق نيكي هيلي القت خطابا بدا وكانه
خطاب نصر وقالت على الرغم من المرتبه
الثانيه فان السباق في بدايته وانها لا
تنوي الانسحاب في اي وقت
قريب بقينا وحدنا امام دونالد ترامب اليوم
حصلنا على نصف الاصوات تقريبا وامامنا
طريق طويل وسنواصل المسير لكن بالنسبه
للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب فان الطريق قد
انتهى امام منافسته نيكي هيلي وان عليها
الانسحاب لان فرص استعاده المبادره تبدو
ضئيله من وجهه نظره على الاقل وفي خطاب
النصر هنا في نيو هامشير انتقل بسرعه الى
موضوعه المفضل والموضوع القريب الى قلب
قاعدته الانتخ خبيه وهو موضوع
الهجره لدينا الملايين من الناس يتدفقون
الى بلدنا بطريقه غير شرعيه ياتون من
السجون ومن المصحات العقليه ويقتلون
بلدنا وفي غياب اي تطورات غير متوقعه وغير
معروفه حتى الان على الاقل يبدو ان
الرجلين دونالد ترامب وجوزيف بايدن قد ضمن
التواجد في اعاده جوله لانتخابات
عام
2020 في وقت تفيد فيه معظم استطلاعات
الراي العام ان اغلبيه الامريكيين لا تريد
اعاده تلك الجوله بين الرجلين لاسباب
متعدده